(audience cheering and clapping)
♪ Remember, not long ago ♪
♪ You called me hysterical ♪
♪ I finally figured us out, yeah ♪
♪ My fire was hot enough ♪
♪ To burn on for the both of us ♪
♪ And your water keeps putting us out ♪
♪ And I should be steam ♪
♪ The way you love to rain over me ♪
♪ Then turn around and
call me your queen ♪
♪ Too blind to see, the way it stings ♪
♪ Lord, the pain it brings ♪
♪ Didn't I give you everything ♪
♪ I gave you everything, baby ♪
♪ Baby ♪
♪ Didn't I ♪
♪ Didn't I give you everything ♪
♪ You got the best of me, baby ♪
♪ Baby ♪
♪ Didn't I ♪
♪ Hear you crying on my shoulder ♪
♪ Beg and hold me till it's over ♪
♪ When you're lonely, just remember ♪
♪ I gave you everything ♪
♪ D-d-didn't I ♪
♪ Hear you crying on my shoulder ♪
♪ Beg and hold me till it's over ♪
♪ When you're lonely, just remember ♪
♪ I gave you everything ♪
♪ D-d-didn't I ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Didn't I, baby ♪
♪ Didn't I ♪
♪ Didn't I give you everything ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Didn't I ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)